la Unión Europea ha prometido hoy a
Turquía y a Siria algo más de mil
millones de dólares que serán para
Turquía hay unos 120 millones de dólares
para Siria como compensación de ayuda
después del terremoto que sacudió el
sureste de Turquía al noroeste de Siria
hace algo más de un mes en una
conferencia de un antes que ha tenido
lugar en Bruselas y en la que han
existido el ministro de exteriores Turco
y el presidente Turco de perdón
telemáticamente que ha agradecido la
Unión Europea está ayudar recordemos que
Turquía es un país candidato para entrar
a la Unión Europea según el Banco
Mundial los desperfectos y los años
creados por este terremoto se apuntan en
torno a 100 mil millones de dólares en
el sureste de Turquía una cifra enorme
sobre todo para una Turquía que tendrá
serias dificultades para paliar los
daños creados
por ese terremoto sobre todo porque
Turquía Lleva años bajo una inflación
una crisis inflacionaria galopante ahora
mismo la inflación en Turquía se sitúa
en torno al 55% sin embargo Esta es la
cifra oficial otras cifras
independientes se sitúan mucho más por
encima del 100% algo que casa mucho más
con lo que sufren los trucos diariamente
que han visto como la clase media del
país ha perdido casi todo su poder
adquisitivo toda esa situación ha creado
muchísimo daño al presidente Turco
recepta y perdón que he visto como su
popularidad de la dañada por esta crisis
económica lo que ha permitido a una
oposición que sea mucho más galvanizada
a través del candidato que fue escogido
hace algo más de una semana que malcele
según la gran mayoría de los sondeos
está por encima del Turco y perdón que
llevan el poder desde hace más de 20
años por primera vez se teme que en
Turquía podría haber en 20 años un
cambio de gobierno